[Music]
[Applause]
Wow it's so weird how you run into
people at the airport didn't you test
we're definitely weird
hear me out Tony that doctor
psychiatrist he's behind all of this
captain your highness
anyway Ross gave me 36 hours to bring in
that was 24 hours ago can you help a
brother out you're after the wrong guy
your judgment is askew your old war
buddy killed innocent people yesterday
and there are five more super soldiers
just like Lee I can't let the doctor
find him first tell me I can't Steve you
know what's about to happen do you
really want to punch your way out of
this one
all right I've run out of patience
underoos
[Music]
nice job kid Thanks well I could have
stuck the landing a little better it's
just a new suit what it's nothing mr.
stark it's perfect thank you yeah we
don't really need to start a
conversation okay cat captain big fan
spider-man yeah we'll talk about it
later
just everyone good Java you've been busy
and you've been a complete idiot dragon
in Clint rescuing Wanda from a place she
doesn't even want to leave a safe place
I'm trying to keep I'm trying to keep
you from tearing the Avengers apart I
did that one you signed
alright we're done you're gonna turn
Barnes over you gonna come with us now
because it's us or squad a JSOC guys
with no compunction about being impolite
we found it the quinjets in hangar 5
north runway
[Music]
all right Lange guys what the hell is
that believe this is yours Captain
America oh great
all right there's two on the parking
deck one of them's Maximoff I'm gonna
grab her broody you want a cap got to
Anna terminal Wilson and Barnes bonds is
Mike
you